hanging on a man you don't think it's a
good idea for a girl to be a
stay-at-home mom like if she has the
option to do that even i would love to
you know yeah when it comes like to have
the the child
like as a woman you have like three
months i don't know in the uk though
mm-hmm like i'd like to like the father
to have those three months at least you
know to be with a child as well you know
i think they put a lot on on the female
perspective like oh she should stay with
the kid but father not as much you know
i think it should be like equality on
that but yeah i mean when it comes to
she should do something otherwise if
this happens how can you leave with a
person well it just that's like just
that's a fear mentality though that's a
fear like there are a lot of like
stay-at-home moms at home school their
kids and that's really good for kids
that's really yeah i mean if you can do
that definitely yeah but i'm just saying
you'd have to depend on a man to do that
you know what i mean yeah and so like i
just think a lot of times we kind of
have this rhetoric that we like can't
depend on men but when men don't leave
most of the time like men again men only
leave 30 of the time
college educated women it's it's 10 so
it's just um it just seems like maybe
that was like something that happened
just because